entschuldigung das mein auge so ein
bisschen entzündet ist aber ich war mal
wieder auf theater unterwegs und hatte
einen afrikaner läuft da hinten die wohl
an dort ja herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen episode
[Musik]
gesundheit im kongo
hallo
es ist nicht total schwierig so kunst
sein die durch manchmal na ja nicht
jeder kann so kurz ein wenig ich
wünschte ich wäre so cool wie du
tja was herz
willkommen zu meiner präsentation zu den
größten unterschieden zwischen der
schweiz und deutschland zuerst über mich
ich bin schweizer und habe eine neutrale
sicht zu diesen themen und ich habe als
kind eine maus ungewollt per hand
umgebracht zum 1
die existenz der schweiz ist
grundsätzlich gut die existenz von
deutschland ist grundsätzlich schlecht
es gibt auch sehenswürdigkeiten in der
schweiz sehr viele das motto wollt ihr
sehen die berge und das bundeshaus auch
in deutschland gibt es
sehenswürdigkeiten zum beispiel der
direkte zug von berlin nach basel
doch weitere sehenswürdigkeiten in der
schweiz gibt es den rheinfall
deutschland ist ein reinfall
fazit von dieser präsentation von
österreich wollen wir gar nicht reden
das wirklich beste präsentation gehörte
aber ist das wirklich so ein ding das
schweiz in österreich so mögen die sich
nicht so
also sie hatte damals während ihrer
schulzeit auf der bühne ein free style
dance battle hat da wohl irgendwas getan
mädel du warst ein kind das kann ich so
peinlich wird
[Musik]
weil ich es will sich wirst du hamburg
also die zwei jungs haben den filter auf
jeden fall verstanden
der filter hat funktioniert halt so dass
du nach links und nach rechts geht was
du halt lieber am markt und
dementsprechend sagte der filter am ende
was für ein tier bist jetzt haben sie
halt die nächste kategorien tag und
nacht entscheiden sie sich doch bitte
zwischen tag und nacht berlin tag &
nacht
[Musik]
ja bin dann leider auch ich
das bin auch ich nur
umgekehrt ausgeredet meine kamera
angeschaltet und ich saß so hier das hat
keine ruhe
ich hab's kurz nicht gemerkt ja hallo
ich bin ein tick tock maria und mache
jetzt einen zaubertrick und dann es ist
irgendwie so und ich verarsche nur
kleine kind ja darunter das locker in
green screen oder ring
[Musik]
ich bin auch ich diese verdammte werbung
kriege ich jedes mal wenn ich auf tour
bin einfach angezeigt und es ist so ein
schwachsinn
also dass ein typ der furz dadurch
unbemerkt in die polizei dann läuft der
weg dann findet er halt mitten in der
wüste soll tresor unnormal viel geld ist
da drin und es plötzlich level 60
mafiaboss jetzt ist er plötzlich so leer
15 sekretärin tötet dann aber zwei
andere leute ist eine 50 weg riet er ist
ja irgendwie wieder level 1 gauner typ
kommt vorbei mit seiner krankenkasse
klaut ihm einfach sein mädchen effekt
auf die fresse und dann natürlich fünf
sekunden später
ist der level 10 attentäter fährten
lamborghini und seine frau will ihn
zurück am feld auf die fresse schickte
dadurch mit direkt runter laden ist
immer wieder schön zu sehen wie kleine
kinder die nicht mehr wissen was tik tok
ist und nicht mehr für sich selbst
sprechen oder entscheiden können dann
irgendwelche werbungen kommerzialisiert
reingezogen das super vor allem wenn die
produkte richtig was bringen
[Musik]
das ist ja so verrückt sie hat nicht nur
extrem viel abgenommen sondern hat
plötzlich auch eine andere augenfarbe
crazy das ist bestimmt nicht eine andere
person
hier sollte man auf dieses mädchen
antworten mit einem video in dem man
eine szene aus beispielsweise in dem
film oder musik oder keine ahnung was
eins zu eins wiedergeben kann
und eine person konnte ihn eine ganz
komische szene eins zu eins wiedergeben
ohne essen werde ich habe eigentlich
immer hunger gefunden habe weil ich das
vorstellen alles aufgefordert habe habe
ich mir habe ich mir für papier genommen
und da habe ich geschaut so gemacht und
das habe ich dann aufgegessen würde ich
beim job interview als seine stärke
anbringen warum mache ich so was immer
wenn ich einfach das heftigste der welt
herausgefunden und ist so lieb und daran
teilhaben zu lassen mit diesem tik tok
die könnten ohne unsere fünf sind also
schmecken riechen hören sehen et cetera
nicht die welt so wahrnehmen wie wir sie
gerade wahrnehmen also da muss ich los
so was kann ich mir den ganzen tag
angucken der lok tagen steigt mir auch
zu kopf ich verstehe jetzt nicht zu
sehen
bekanntes lied das war immer der
unangenehmste moment ne man hat gefühlt
immer gebetet als im film an gemacht
wurde und der lehrer sagte man setze ich
mich denn hin dass er nicht neben einen
kommt und wenn der dann eben mich
gekommen ist dann musst du halt die
ganze zum mitschreiben und ich hatte
auch immer schiss bei der dann auf
meinem zettel geguckt hatte ich dachte
ich darf jetzt keine scheiße
mitschreiben und so und sonst war film
gucken immer sofort entspannt an der
stelle wo heute hier wieso detektivs
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat er das
gern einen daumen hoch unter video
abonniert nur ein kanal falls sie morgen
das neue micro wie du nicht verpassen
wollt und komme ich heute zum ende noch
einen live